LET'S GO TO GABE STERLING, THE
CHIEF OPERATING OFFICER AT THE
GEORGIA SECRETARY OF STATE
OFFICE.
YOU KNOW, GABE, AS WOLF AND I
ARE SITTING HERE, CNN PROJECTING
THAT THE SENATE RACE BETWEEN
SENATOR WARNOCK AND HERSCHEL
WALKER IS INDEED HEADED TO A
RUNOFF.
ARE YOU READY FOR THAT?
>> WELL, FIRST THINGS FIRST WE
HAVE TO GOT AN IDEA OF WHAT
WOLF'S IDEA OF EXCITING IS.
>> SO YOU'RE READY FOR THAT AND
I KNOW JOHN KING IS WITH ME AND
HAS A SPECIFIC QUESTION ABOUT
THE RUNOFF AND WHAT YOU'RE
LOOKING AT.
JOHN, GO AHEAD.
>> THE INFORMATION WE DON'T
HAVE, I'M TRYING TO GET TO THE
POINT WHY ARE YOU CERTAIN IT
WILL BE A RUNOFF IF YOU LOOK AT
THE RESULT, IT'S 49.2-48.7 AND
THE ESTIMATED OUTSTANDING VOTE
HERE, MAYBE YOU HAVE UPDATED
NUMBERS.
WE HAVE IT AT 96% ESTIMATED
REPORTING AND YOU STILL SEE IN
THESE CIRCLES A DECENT AMOUNT OF
VOTE, DECENT SHARE TO COME IN IN
FULLEN COUNTY AND SUBURBS AROUND
IT WHERE SENATOR WARNOCK IS
DOING WELL.
YOU'RE CERTAIN THAT THERE'S
ABSOLUTELY NO POSSIBILITY HE
GETS TO 50?
>> AT 2:00 A.M. I TWEETED OUT
IT'S PRETTY SAFE TO SAY WE'LL
HAVE THAT RUNOFF AS WE GET
CLOSER AND CLOSER, MORE VOTES
KEEP COMING IN.
BY OUR INTERNAL ESTIMATES WE
HAVE LESS THAN 10,000 VOTES TO
GO UNTIL ELECTION FLIGHT
REPORTING FOR FINAL COUNTS AND
SEEN SOME OF THESE.
WE KNOW THERE'S LESS THAN 10,000
SO THERE'S NOT ENOUGH NUMBERS
OUT THERE STILL TO CHANGE THE
OUTCOME OF THIS RACE.
>> SO WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT IT,
GABE, YOU KNOW, YOU'VE GOT NOW
AS YOU SAID 27 DAYS AND 6 HOURS
OR WHATEVER YOU JUST LAID OUT
TILL THE POLLS CLOSE, YOU'VE
ALREADY MOVED AHEAD FOR THAT
BUT, LOOK, YOU CAN RUN -- JOHN
KING CAN RUN A SCENARIO WHERE
CONTROL OF THE SENATE RESTS ON
GEORGIA.
WE'LL SEE WHAT HAPPENS IN
ARIZONA AND NEVADA BUT, AGAIN,
ALL EYES AGAIN COULD BE ON
GEORGIA, CONTROL OF THE SENATE
COULD REST ON GEORGIA.
WHAT ARE THE NEXT FEW WEEKS
GOING TO LOOK LIKE AS YOU GET
READY FOR THAT?
>> WELL, I TALKED TO SECRETARY
RAFFENSPERGER BACK IN THE SUMMER
AND ASKED WHAT WOULD HAPPEN.
I SAID GIVEN THE FACT WE ARE
GEORGIA IT'S OBVIOUSLY GOING TO
BE A RUNOFF WITH CONTROL OF THE
UNITED STATES SENATE ON THE LINE
BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT WE DO HERE
SO WHAT WE'RE GOING TO BE DOING
REALLY AS FAR AS THE
ADMINISTRATION SIDE WE HAVE
ALREADY LINED UP TO BEGIN
BUILDING THE BALLOTS.
ALL WILL BE TO THE COUNTIES BY
NOVEMBER 14th FOR THEIR SIGNOFF
AND BEGIN THE ABSENTEE BALLOT
PORTAL IS OPEN AND CAN BEGIN
REQUESTING THEM.
THE COUNTIES NEED A MINIMUM OF
FIVE DAYS OF EARLY VOTING.
VERY GOOD POSSIBILITY THAT WE'LL
PROBABLY HAVE VOTING ON
SATURDAY, NOVEMBER 26th IN MANY
OF THE COUNTIES IF THEY SO
CHOOSE AND PLANNING FOR THAT
RIGHT NOW.
BUT IT'S REALLY ABOUT GETTING
ALL THE PARTS LINED UP SO WE CAN
GET AS MANY VOTES IN SO THE
VOTERS CAN MAKE THEIR VOICE
HEARD ON THAT RUNOFF.
>> SO JUST TO BRING SOMETHING
HOME THAT EVA WAS REPORTING ON,
YOU SEE HERSCHEL WALKER
UNDERPERFORMING WHERE YOUR
GOVERNOR BRIAN KEMP PERFORMED.
HE EASILY WON RE-ELECTION.
THE SECRETARY OF STATE BRAD
RAFFENSPERGER WON RE-ELECTION
WITH 53% OF THE VOTE.
THAT'S A NINE PERCENTAGE POINT
MARGIN OF VICTORY.
THESE WERE WINS, RIGHT?
THESE ARE TWO PEOPLE WHO
REPEATEDLY RESISTED DONALD
TRUMP'S EFFORTS TO OVERTURN THE
ELECTION IN YOUR STATE AND YET
THEY CRUISED TO RE-ELECTION
VICTORY AS REPUBLICANS DESPITE
TRUMP ATTACKING THEM CONSTANTLY.
HERSCHEL WALKER IS A PERSON
TRUMP HAS STOOD FULLY BEHIND.
WHAT MESSAGE DO YOU THINK THE
VICTORIES THAT YOU'RE SEEING IN
GEORGIA IN TWO CASES AND THE
RUNOFF IN A THIRD SENDS TO
DONALD TRUMP?
>> I THINK THE MAIN THING IS YOU
SEE IF YOU STOOD WITH DONALD
TRUMP YOU DIDN'T NECESSARILY
LOOK LIKE YOU CAME OUT TOO WELL
AT THE END OF THE DAY.
I MEAN, FRANKLY, WITH THE PEOPLE
THAT TRUMP HELPED GET THE SENATE
NOMINATIONS, WE PROBABLY LOST
NEW HAMPSHIRE ON THE REPUBLICAN
SIDE AND PROBABLY LOST
PENNSYLVANIA BECAUSE OF THAT.
IF McCORMICK WAS THE NOMINEE
MOST SAY WE WOULD HAVE WON
PENNSYLVANIA AND THE BALANCE OF
THE SENATE WOULD NOT BE ON THE
LINE IN GEORGIA MORE THAN LIKELY
SO I THINK THE MAIN MESSAGE IS
VOTERS WANT STABILITY AND THEY
WANT CANDIDATES WHO STAND UP FOR
THEMSELVES ON THEIR OWN ISSUES
AND NOT NECESSARILY TIED TO ONE
PERSONALITY OR ANOTHER.
>> WELL, GABE, THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
YOU HEAR IT HEADING TO A RUNOFF
IN GEORGIA IN 27 DAYS.
THANK YOU SO MUCH, GABE.